let's go next to dan from the united
kingdom dan you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can
oh that's good i'm on my airpods so if
the sound goes i'm sorry um i kind of
had a couple of questions um sorry if i
ramble a bit um one kind of concerned
sort of political apathy um because i'm
aware i only basically followed this
because if we obviously got our own
troubles over here the virginia governor
race i noted that there was about
um 3.3 million votes in the in that race
and that's kind of a high compared to
sort of previous elections but right
when you think about that in sort of
comparison to the presidential election
that was kind of a million votes lower
and then when you think about sort of
primary votes um more broadly they're
often
sort of miles lower than the actual
general election but that's where you
can kind of get the most
ideological diversity amongst the
parties and you could probably get the
most change how do you think we could so
or how we i mean countries more general
where you've got sort of
forty percent of the pop of the public
not voting even in the main elections
and sort of local government here you
sometimes elections can barely get 20 of
the vote
and they control a lot of power so i
don't know what your thoughts are on
that one so listen there's a couple
different answers to this one answer is
that
i the idealistic answer would be well
listen uh the way we get people
interested here dan is we have to make
sure everybody understands the direct
link between they're going out to vote
even in midterms and local municipal
elections and the things that happen in
their community as soon as you explain
this to people you're gonna see voter
turnout increase dramatically it's kind
of bs in the sense that it's been tried
so many ways and it just never really
seems to work like there's just no
turnout in the us and then there's even
lower turnout for midterms it's just
there's just lower turnout and the
problem with that is that it
disproportionately helps whoever can be
the most salacious
in their campaign and in virginia it was
republicans who used fear and anger to
get republican voters out to fight
critical race theory which they wrongly
believe is being taught in schools so my
real answer would be like the idealistic
answer is let's just explain to people
how important it is to participate it
doesn't really work very well
a lot of people see it almost as a badge
of honor that they don't work they don't
they don't vote rather some people see
it as a badge of honor not to work but
we're talking about voting here they see
it as a badge of honor not to vote and
if voting is not mandatory that's uh
considered completely valid and that
that's that's the way it is so the next
step would be well just you make voting
mandatory like it is in many countries
yeah i just don't think you're going to
see it in the u.s i think it goes
against sort of like the idea of the of
the funding fundamental principles of
the united states it wouldn't even
happen
yeah right exactly wouldn't even happen
so then
i think where we end up unfortunately
dan is
we have to accept that 40 percent of
eligible voters won't vote in
presidential elections and 60 won't vote
in midterms and you just have to figure
out how do you win and achieve change
given that uh reality uh it's it's it's
depressing i know but i think that
that's where we're yeah no
um i don't know if you've got time for
one more um it was kind of sort of
linked to this it's i guess like when
you kind of you can i guess in any
election you might get sort of a dozen
or so kind of broad categories of policy
discussed but often that as you've kind
of talked about something like critical
race theory or the opposition to
teaching of something which isn't really
taught yeah is i guess if you if you
kind of line up things by sort of the
harm they cause so i guess climate
change could be one corruption could be
another lack of healthcare and so on but
these sometimes can get the least kind
of they're the ones that do the most
damage where they get the least focus is
there kind of is there a way of sort of
like as maybe as activists or about
convincing the media changing the media
environment how do you kind of reach
sort of recur is there a way to
recalibrate a sort of public discourse
to focus on things that cause sort of
the most heart
rather than something like you know like
the result the risk of dying from cobalt
is like a hundred times or
greater than being killed unfortunately
unless you change the infrastructure
around how corporate media works you're
not going to change that because when
you have profit driven
media
that wants to focus on the most
salacious and titillating stories
unless you change the fact that there's
a big reward for that i don't know how
you make the changes to the discourse
that you're talking about i mean part of
it would be counter options so we've
seen the growth of long-form podcast
discussions and all these different
things and that's great but it's also
great because it's profitable too right
if it were completely not viable then
you wouldn't see that either so that's
more of a cultural thing i don't think
you change it by changing media i think
media will change as the culture changes
around what's profitable and what what
gets eyeballs
yeah no i have to i often kind of move
towards like sometimes i don't was
listening to sort of long-form podcasts
or long-form discussions about a single
topic rather than sort of like by
clickbait
headlines because they don't really go
into any debt so i kind of
try and diversify what i'm listening to
beyond just typical headlines although
so the bbc does a decent job here they
may not be brilliant but at least
they're not like
that you can get in-depth explainers on
there so they do typically a better job
but they're still perfect
thanks for taking my question pleasure
dan from the uk great to hear from you
let's see if he can redeem himself i'm
gonna go to eric from cancun who had a
disastrous call last time he called in
uh eric i'm i'm giving you another shot
okay
uh-oh
eric you gotta unmute yourself my friend
oh boy
going from bad to worse for eric from
cancun
eric you are on the air this is your
last chance you've got to unmute
yourself or configure your microphone
otherwise we're not going to be able to
talk
all right there it is eric from cancun
attempting to
redeem himself but it didn't work it
just didn't work
let's try um let's try kevin from
seattle kevin you're on the air
mr pacman can you hear me i can
excellent uh thanks for taking my call
um
i have a question related to
infrastructure and i don't know what
like what your opinion is on this but
i think leaving the bipartisan
infrastructure built
um leaving idle is
very risky
like
it doesn't help biden's approval ratings
or democrats approval rate especially
terry
mcauliffe it doesn't help the furloughed
workers who are working to fix our
infrastructure and it sucks up so much
oxygen in congress
from other issues
and
the american people like the bipartisan
infrastructure build and want to see and
feel like
those representing them could get
something accomplished for once so
my question is
like is there a korean credence to like
the moderate position from like a
progressive point of view like is
holding up the infrastructure build
damaging to the material interests of
the american people yeah so i think
leaving the bill idle is bad for
everybody i think either listen
vote
on the bill
kill the bill if that's what people in
congress want to do house and senate
or pass some version of the bill and
it's time to move on it's been going on
for months um these bills are by and
large popular with the american people
there's disagreements about specific
elements of it but i completely agree
with you just the the ongoing
negotiation used to get oxygen by people
like uh kirsten cinema joe manchin and
others um it's not it's it's a disaster
for the american people it's gotta end
and just letting it sit idle also is
wrong so either kill it or pass it and
then we've gotta move on to the next
thing i agree with you 100
uh all right uh i think that i think
that's
that's all i
i think if if anything i cannot wrap my
head around like what what
um
why why um those students who are like
in opposite in opposition like why is
this like the the hill to die on um like
if we care about the the american people
then
i think we shouldn't think the bill
should be voted on based on on its
merits rather than just
i don't know those are just i don't
think they see it as a hill to die on
they're just like yeah i'm just i'm not
the people who are sort of like just
against it which is basically
republicans joe manchin keeps talking
about it because he's using it to get
attention and he may actually ultimately
vote for it republicans aren't really
dying on the hill they're just like yeah
we don't want it so we don't support it
and then and then they move on so it's
actually doing far more damage to
democrats kevin i gotta run i appreciate
the call kevin from seattle i appreciate
everybody i was able to speak to today
that's going to do it for today we're
going to go to a break i hope to speak
to you again next time we take live
calls